george two of three from the field
curry with a catch in two three he
knocks it in he's not trying to do too
much i
believe he's ultimately thinking he's
not playing for right now he's playing
to build these guys because he's going
to be stepped first you still have to
compete
and follow game plan what a play by lou
williams in transition
morris missing and curry quickly the
other way
pulls up from deep got it splashed
curry blue will
off the mark loose ball
warriors control they got a little bit
of time basemore
out to curry catch and shoot got it
smoke from steph to end the third
quarter
and this is exactly what draymond green
was talking about reading and reacting
finding steph curry runs the floor can't
bear as much turns
finds him in rhythm do that dance
curry guarded by ibaka
staff on the drive by wild tough shot
circus time steph curry steph curry
with you watch him do this in pregame
and in the safe hands the productive
prolific hands
of steph curry
in his bag deep like the fries are at
the bottom
descending performance here by curry
martin says the paul george allowed me
to have this dance
that's a big top move and in my opinion
it is rated pg
that's not fair